treize ans après la pose de la première
pierre le bâtiment de 3000 mètres carrés
sur trois niveaux est encore ouvert à
tous les vents le chantier a même connu
quatre ans d'inactivité
lentement il reprend vie aujourd'hui au
gré des dons financiers consentis par la
communauté musulmane et ses 35 mille
fidèles en indre et loire il faut
boucler un budget de 6 millions d'euros
à part l'algérie qui a consenti une aide
de 800 mille euros les pays sollicités
n'ont pas donné suite du koweit le qatar
du saoudien
marocain
les algériens même pas puisque je passe
à travers ce qui est pas et ça a été une
fin de non recevoir ben disons que les
chais nouveau dossier on va étudier on
veut répondre à echallens
quand on vous dit cela ça veut dire
la peine d'attendre
la dernière réalisation ce dôme qui
vient chapeauter la grande salle de
prière elle pourra accueillir jusqu'à
7000 fidèles en attendant ils
s'installeront d'ici la fin de l'année
dans le futur parking évidemment les
conditions d'exercice de la foi seront
précaire pour le moment la priorité est
à la protection des lieux là on a posé
le bac à bac acier on a posé la laine de
roche pour isoler et là on a posé dans
gt pour ta remis tout simple on est là
pour ça pour fermer ont empêché de l'eau
rentrait lorsqu'elle ouvrira ses portes
la mosquée de tours et son minaret
feront face à la basilique saint martin
comme un symbole de fraternité entre les
deux religions catholique et musulmane